[Music]
what's up wisecrack helen again
this summer audiences got an arguably
unnecessary addition to one of cinema's
most
perfect trilogies with toy story 4. the
original three films about a band of
spunky sentient children's playthings
grappled with surprisingly deep
questions about love
loss identity being forgotten moving on
and more
this was a pinnacle achievement in
children's cinema in which sequels often
feel like clumsy
narratively gratuitous cash grabs so we
went into this fourth film wondering
is there really anything left for the
series to say or are we just pandering
to randy newman fans at this point
let's investigate in this wisecrack
edition on toy story 4
deeper dumb and of course spoilers ahead
alright guys let's dive into a recap toy
story 4 starts with a flashback to the
young andy days
as woody watches bo pete being given
away she asks him to come with her but
he decides
bros before bows and stays with andy
flash forward to teenage andy giving
woody and code to a hyperactive kid
named bonnie
even as bonnie becomes increasingly less
interested in woody his loyalty leads
him to follow her to kindergarten where
he helps her create forky
which is exactly what it sounds like a
spork with mismatched googly eyes and
pipe cleaner arms
bonnie effin loves forkey but fork he
thinks he's trash and keeps trying to
end it all in the nearest rubbish bin
woody has to prevent forkey from
trashing himself when bonnie's family
heads out on an rv trip
mishaps ensue and forkey is promptly
kidnapped in an antique store by a
sinister doll
gabby gabby and her horrifying
marionette minions lost on a playground
a hapless woody runs into his old boo
bo peep who was standing the lost toy
lifestyle together the gang sets out on
an elaborate quest to rescue bonnie's
beloved plastic spork from gabby gabby
only it turns out gabby gabby just wants
woody's voice box to replace her
defective one
so she can convince a little girl to
love her woody agrees to give up his
voice box that marionette performs some
quick black market surgery
and in exchange woody gets forkey back
everything culminates at the carnival
grounds where woody finds his calling as
a lost toy
and decides that this time he'll stay
with bo they then devote themselves to
helping toys find their own way
the end now pixar is known for making
some of the best written and most
thoughtful films out there
and the toy story movies are no
exception so we think it's worth asking
if woody's emotional journey is about
more than regretting a breakup with a
hot shepherd we've come up with three
possible interpretations of the film to
run by you guys
our first argument toy story 4 is a tale
of
existential awakening the first three
films have brushed against existential
themes
asking what it means to be a toy who
loves and is loved or
no longer loved but in this fourth film
it really goes there
nearly every character in the film has
some kind of conflict with the inner
voice that governs their decision-making
process
buzz struggles to make sense of his
factory issue dialogue how do i get out
of here
well woody grapples with his own
conscience to parse what he should do
from what he wants to do meanwhile
forkey's poor plastic spork brain
insists
that he is trash and gabby longs to fix
her voice box so she can speak the words
her toy makers intended her to
to grasp how the inner voice speaks to a
key element of existentialism
we're looking to one bespectacled french
philosopher jean-paul sartre
sartre believed that we are all
radically free and because of that
it's up to us to determine who we become
based on our choices
you choose the path you walk the ice
cream flavor you eat and the youtube
videos you watch
algorithm be damned in his essay
existentialism is a humanism
sartre famously wrote that existence
precedes essence
explaining that first of all man exists
turns up
appears on the scene and only afterwards
defines himself
basically there is no essence that
defines you from birth you first exist
then your essence is defined by your
choices
you aren't born the kind of person who
wears pleated khakis for fun
you become that when you choose to wear
your school uniform to parties these
choices define your character
in this way we can see bo peep as the
consummate existentialist
she's broken free from her obligations
as a toy belonging to children
and no longer feels compelled to live by
any outside creed
this separation from the rules and
expectations of her past is symbolized
in her freeing herself from the lamp
that she came with
she runs a mug exploring the world and
playing with whatever kids she wants
most importantly she doesn't blame
anyone for her choices
she is accountable to no one and holds
no one accountable for herself
she is free the other characters are all
struggling with non-existential thinking
they define themselves not by the
individual choices they make
but by their essence as toys as defined
by their quote unquote inner voice
this is apparent in woody's
single-minded devotion to bonnie he sees
it as his duty to serve her
even though she's clearly no longer
interested in playing with him
regardless he feels like he can't make
the choice to be a toy without a kid
similarly forkey sees himself as
essentially made from trash
and thus identifies entirely as said
trash rather than as a toy
no toys they're all toys
trash this line of thought is especially
apparent in the toys that were born
defective
for gabby gabby whose voice box doesn't
work her failure to fully embody her
design functionality makes her sub par
and justifies her sometimes cruel
actions or take do kaboom
who in not being able to jump through
his hoop failed to live up to the
impossible expectations set by his
commercials
that failure we see has become an excuse
to do nothing with his life but weep and
bemoan what could have been
for these two characters their inability
to embody an aspect of their supposed
essence haunts them
they define themselves not by the
choices they make but by a perceived
lack with which they were born
and thus are miserable now because
sartre believed that the choices we make
determine our essence
he was also big on the idea of personal
responsibility
or as he puts it man is nothing else but
what he makes of himself
this might sound fun at first don't we
all want to be in control of our own
lives and eat ice cream for breakfast
it's not that simple though because a
dude's choices determine his destiny
he is responsible for everything he does
so
when you get cavities you got nobody to
blame but yourself
as a result sartre doesn't see freedom
as a fun walk in the park
in fact he writes that man is condemned
to be free
a lot of people find that freedom hard
to take which is why
you know cults this conflict around
accepting personal responsibility for
your choices
is probably best embodied by buzz
lightyear whenever he's faced with a
tough decision
buzz presses one of his buttons and
waits for his programming to issue a
command
calling this his inner voice rather than
take responsibility for his choices he
simply outsources them
this can occasionally help him get out
of a jam what would he do
jump out of a moving vehicle what would
he do
it's a secret mission in a chartered
space let's go but doesn't always yield
the most helpful advice
what are you doing i'm thinking this is
also reflected in woody's preoccupation
with his inner voice
while buzz's inner voice was literally
manufactured by a factory
woodys was developed after years of
believing that a toy only exists for the
joy of a kid
as a result he sees his duties as
clearly defined he has to help bonnie
however he can
as he puts it i need to do this that
little voice inside me would never leave
me alone if i gave up
this is despite the fact that bonnie's
really over him here we could say that
woody is acting in
bad faith or what sartre would refer to
as the state of pretending that you're
not free
in a burn happy quote sartre says only a
being which was free
and which knew it was free would go out
of its way as we all do
to pretend it's not free in the first
scene of the film
woody pretends that he doesn't have the
freedom to leave andy behind and run
away with bo peep
sartro would say that he does and the
only thing that stopped him was his
choice not to
throughout the course of the film we
watch as each character basically
becomes
through a star tree and lens kind of
really human
most importantly what he chooses to stay
with bo peep
thus embracing his radical freedom and
rejecting his supposed essential purpose
of being a child plaything even though
leaving his child behind
once seemed unfathomable he realizes
that he
can and so he does existential crisis
averted
importantly buzz too has his own free
will affirmed during a critical moment
he needs bonnie to bring the family back
to the antique store to rescue woody and
forkey
but she just won't notice that she left
her backpack behind
after his buttons failed to guide him he
uses his own voice
your backpack's at the antique store
let's go oh no my backpack
here buzz recognizes that he can't rely
on his factory-issued inner voice
and is forced to take action to save the
day to make a choice
when we first meet gabby gabby she has
an almost religious attachment to her
own mythos
reading her illustrated companion book
as if it's a biblical text
and treating tea time with her
inattentive god harmony
as if it is a spiritual right her life
is defined by her desire to please
harmony
and she goes to extraordinary lengths to
do so but then
even when her voice box is fixed she's
still rejected by her
and the narrative in the book is proven
false with the help of woody and beau
she learns that she's not at the mercy
of the gabby gabby mythos
that it's up to her to define herself
and her worth through the choices she
makes
similarly sartre's whole shtick is
predicated on the belief that god does
not exist
because there's no bearded dude in the
sky controlling our lives it must be up
to us to choose our own path
when gabby gabby encounters the lost
little girl at the fair she chooses to
offer herself up for adoption
sure she's submitting to the ownership
model that woody's about to leave behind
but she's openly choosing it over the
alternative similarly
ducky and bunny the lovable key and peel
carnival toys
go from wanting to passively be chosen
by a child who will love them
to becoming super active freedom
fighters busting other stuffed animals
out of the carnival booth purgatory they
loathed
meanwhile duke kaboom at the urging of
woody and beau
chooses to leap on his motorcycle first
four feet then
forty in spite of the fact that he won't
land perfectly like he's supposed to in
the commercial
he's learned to no longer live by the
standards dictated by his design
that friends is called freedom and we
can't forget forkey
easily the weirdest character in the toy
story cannon early on
forkey identifies as trash he was made
to be a spork
and should have wound up in the warm
warm embrace of the garbage
i am not a toy i'm a spark be quiet
i was made for soup salad maybe chili
and then the trash
i'm litter freedom
however with the help of woody he
realizes that he isn't a slave to his
inner voice
he can establish a new identity as a toy
who is loved by bonnie
he's so thoroughly inculcated to his own
freedoms that
by the end of the film he's even
prepared to pass on some of that
existential wisdom to his new love
interest
we are all toys unique
beautiful toys each character's
narrative arc shows them grow from a
character
who accepts the destiny thrust upon them
to an almost
eerily human-like being who makes
choices that have consequences
and thus exhibits autonomy over their
own existence
that's pretty beautiful we'd grade this
interpretation as a cool a
and say that viewed through this lens
the film is deep with a capital d
so now that we've gotten the existential
mind out of the way
it's time for our second interpretation
that beau peep is the miltonian satan
i know hear us out in the world of these
toys children are basically godlike
creatures who they spend their lives
serving
they live their lives for their children
just as a religious person might live
their life for god
in fact the godliness of children in
this world is made pretty literal with
the introduction of forkey
an inanimate object to bonnie through
the sheer power
of childish wonder whimsy and a couple
of googly eyes brings to life
it's also worth noting the almost
religious reverence that the toys have
for their children
no i can't sir bo i need to get back to
my kid
what you got a kid yeah way to beat the
odds soldier
recall the way gabby gabby reads her
book like a bible similarly
duke spends all his time bemoaning the
way he let down his former child owner
and when he performs a life-threatening
stunt it's his child's face that appears
to
him like a divine mirage in this context
bo peep has committed the ultimate sin
she's rejected children
and in doing so rejected god in john
milton's famous epic paradise lost
a prideful satan is depicted as being
cast out from heaven and condemned to
hell
after a failed rebellion against god he
didn't accept god's dominion over him
and thought all angels should rule as
gods themselves similarly
popeep didn't want to belong to a child
anymore she wanted to be her
own master when she and woody reunite
after years
he assumes that she must be devastated
not to have a child
instead she seems free almost ecstatic
perhaps fittingly
moments earlier the pair fall down a
hill is it a stretch to see this
then as woody satanic fall from his role
as the eternally devout toy
hmm maybe there's more though
satan is practically defined by his
predilections as a tempter
in gurtha's faust a devil tries to
convince faust to sell his soul in
exchange for
all worldly pleasures telling him to
sample every possible delight
grasp at what you want similarly bo peep
lures woody away from the quiet safe
world he has known
all his life she embodies temptation
compelling woody with promises of
exciting carnivals and far-flung lands
if we do take this interpretation
seriously it's also worth noting the fun
reversal of traditional christian
imagery
bo peep is a shepherd just like jesus
except she's leading toys away from the
flock
she's really the anti-shepherd
encouraging everyone to go their own way
in life
free of the responsibility they all feel
to their sometimes unappreciative
children
now before you raise your eyebrows too
high know that we'd only grade this
interpretation of square
c plus if you can't quite picture bo
peepwear and devil horns
that's okay we've got one more
interpretation for you
we see some definite psychological
complexes exhibited by forky and it
helps explain why he desperately wants
to bathe in trash
to understand this let's look at sigmund
freud and otto rank
now freud describes birth or leaving the
womb as the first experience of anxiety
and thus the source and prototype of
anxiety his one-time colleague otto rank
took it further
suggesting that birth isn't just
anxiety-inducing
it's actually traumatic the greatest
trauma of life in fact
think about it you go from the
reasonably chill quiet world of your
mom's womb
to a weird outside world where your
mom's screaming fluorescent lights are
shining and then some doctor spanx your
butt
not the kind of activity you want to
repeat so now consider that forkey's
birth of sorts took place in the
kindergarten classroom where he was
clumsily pieced together by bonnie from
disparate pieces of trash
as indicated by the first noise he makes
when he becomes vocal
[Music]
farky's birth seems to have been at
least a little traumatic
frank notes that the resulting trauma
from birth leads us to long for a return
to our primal state
noting that every pleasure has as its
final aim
the re-establishment of the intrauterine
primal pleasure
basically we have a desire to return to
the womb even though we definitely
wouldn't fit anymore
as a result we experience infantile
regression which means that we'll seek
out replacements for our mom's womb in
various objects or other people which a
freudian might say is the reason you
enjoy jacuzzis
sorry anyway we see some hardcore
infantile regression coming from forkie
who desperately seeks to return to his
own womb which is to say
the trash and what becomes one of the
film's funniest bits forky gleefully
throws himself into every trashcan he
can find
he reverently calls out for trash the
way a child might call out for their own
mother and exhibits the same kind of
clingy longing that a newborn might
when woody asks him why he's so obsessed
with trash cans he gives an answer that
would certainly raise otto rank's
eyebrow
it's warm ew it's cozy i guess and safe
like somebody's whispering in your ear
everything's gonna be okay
if that's not infantile regression i
don't know what is
okay but real talk we'll give forky's
garbage womb interpretation a solid c
now whether or not you buy any of these
ways of reading the film
i think we can all agree that pixar
created another extremely thoughtful
emotionally powerful film with toy story
4. and at least for our favorite reading
it seems like the geniuses at pixar have
created a toy-sized mirror for some of
the anxieties we may be facing in an
increasingly secular world
but what do you guys think do you buy
the toy story as an existentialist saga
or do you think it's more in line with
our not so secret desire to crawl back
into a nice big womb
let us know in the comments
[Applause]
[Music]
you